dans sa résidence de takhar le président
de la république du sénégal léopold
sédar senghor vit entouré de nombreux
amis
le président senghor qui vient
d'annoncer sa décision de quitter le
pouvoir a accordé il y a quelques mois
un entretien à 38 ans un homme de
lettres mais aussi amis de la nature
il évoque notamment sa passion pour les
oiseaux et les poèmes que lui a inspiré
le monde animal sensibilité particulière
pour la vie en général pour le monde
végétal mais surtout pour le monde
animal d'ailleurs vous me voyez dans ce
parc du palais de la république
requiem plein d'arbres de fleurs
d'oiseaux
c'est vous dire que depuis mon enfance
je me suis toujours sans vie près de la
nature
déjà quand j'étais jeune quand j'étais à
la mission des pères du saint-esprit un
réseau bill près de mon village natal
glv des tourterelles dans une cage c'est
le président que l'animal peut être un
ami de l'homme l'animal peut être un ami
de l'homme aristote le disait déjà que
les animaux avaient une âme et pierre
teilhard de chardin nous dit qu'il y à
l'esprit même au sein de la matière
nos seins de l'après vie et que la vie
est une complexification de la matière
c'est la raison pour laquelle le j'ai
l'impression que tout la nature vivante
que tout ce qui est en vie et surtout
l'animal que tout ce qui est en vie aia
donc on va donc son merveilleux vous les
à des tâches vinci pour la beauté votre
équipe en finale je n'ai choisi parce
que ce sont des compagnons le lisent
oiseaux et les animaux sont aux parents
et le ils tiennent compagnie et c'est
très important pour un continent comme
l'a fait vous savez que c'est en afrique
que l'homme a émergé de l'animalité il
ya ces millions cinq cent mille ans et
en afrique
il y à une symbiose l'intimité entre la
nature l homme plus particulièrement
entre les animaux et l'homme animaux et
une âme ces oiseaux là pensé goûter au
surinam elles ont de l'unam d'animal une
aime beaucoup plus simple naturelle
mentale à l'autre
comme vous le savez les grues couronnées
sont des oiseaux sauvages
j'admire leur beauté leur élégance et
les grues que vous voyez ce premier dans
les parcs
c'est ma femme qui les a élevés je ne
dirais pas hausse mais c'est ma femme
qui les a brise ogni et qui les a
nourris
je n'aurais jamais cru qu'on pu
apprivoiser à ce point des grues
couronnées
elles peuvent voler n'est ce pas elle
vole elles s'en vont et elles reviennent
ils sont combien elle va elle doit être
une dizaine un matin à d'autres oiseaux
parce que nous avons six paires auquel
le don cadre de la forêt amazonienne de
telle sorte que ces perroquets le
s'adapte très bien à notre climat et à
notre ville à des vacances nous avons
des pigeons et de tourterelles c'est
démontré monsieur le président votre un
monstre du frêche on protège ans
une réserve qui se trouve un peu partout
à travers ce week-end pouvez vous nous
enfermez 7 est une entreprise très
difficile mais c'est moi qui ai songé à
créer départ nous avons actuellement ces
parcs nationaux dont deux parcs royaux
le parc des îles de la madeleine
en face le dakar est là le parc de
djoudj est ce qu'il veut nous inspire le
poète léopold sédar senghor les aliments
expire le bois est les oiseaux inspire
comme vous pouvez vous en rendre compte
en lisant mes poèmes et ce sont des
oiseaux réel que je connais des fêtes de
l'allégorie là dedans a donc mon salaire
vous savez vous serez quand le poète
écrit qu'est ce que c'est que la poésie
ce sont des images analogiques et
rythmée de telle sorte que quand je
parle des monologues de barbarie ou des
guêpiers de nubie ou de combat sous du
sénégal ça une valeur symbolique du
moins dans l'esthétique négro-africaine
mis une aspiration réelle inspiration
art and see vollèges dégrise chambre
ceux qui autour de moi les la nature les
arbres les animaux avec lesquels je vis
en afrique que vous savez monsieur le
président
c'est à niveau c'est plus on est
important et ses élus le sont devenus
célèbres parce que du temps de haut
commissaire il y avait peut-être des
chiens mais il n'y avait pas d'oiseaux
il n'y avait surtout pas de grue et en
afrique je n'ai jamais rencontré ses
grues dans un palais présidentiel encore
une fois cela vielle de l'enfance
je suis rural je suis né à la campagne
je suis venu en ville à dakar l'âge de
15 ans elle j'ai voulu reconstituer ici
et dans toute ma vie si vous
l'atmosphère animales et végétales de
mon enfance cima si mon père était un
propriétaire terrien ma mère était la
fille d'un paysan moyens j'ai encore des
cousins germains qui sont des pays
touchés mais c'est des fluides en cours
vous dire que l'homme a besoin
d'animaux amis faut vivre pour être
heureux le mât besoin de vivre au milieu
de la nature l'homme a besoin des arbres
des fleurs et des animaux les flamands
roses suspect j'ai également chanté les
flamands roses
non
tél
rien
pas